you look amazing where your snacks next
I have a protein bar in my purse that
you can I like a mint situation I like a
little water Reese wants a mint Reese
get some in thank you oh my god these
are do you carry a purse what are you
keeping you're like a little purse yes
I've got lipstick I've got powder I've
got my phone now we have a helicopter
coming at me talking to all these
fabulous people with that Brad there you
go it's right I've been popping them all
night I really check it bad okay big
night for you morning show and big
little lies all of your loves are here
represented today now I feel so grateful
so blessed to be here with these
incredible women Nicole Kidman Laura
Dern shailene Woodley's here I'm so
Jennifer Aniston the past the morning
show
yeah we just saw Jen going by looking
gorgeous you guys are in the same
category yeah okay so what is that like
do you say no no you were bed no no she
says you're there's like what the heck
we need more think we're presenting
together top of the show so we're like
what are we gonna say so mainly now we
just check in with each other and we're
so we we both have an attitude of
gratitude just this is so fun you know
what I think it's cool like a lot of the
folks a lot of the Hollywood a-listers
that you want to call them that I've
been talking to tonight asking them what
they're watching they say the morning
show people love it so nice I was on a
holiday and everybody was so lovely and
saying they loved the show and it means
so much to them so that's what you try
to do is make stuff that resonates in
culture and hopefully it's doing that I
want to know when you sleep because now
you have little fires everywhere coming
in March
so number one win do you sleep number
two how excited are you
I live when I sleep I sleep pretty hard
I'm no it's just a great time you know
my dad always just say you gotta make
hay while the Sun shines so I'm just
really trying hard to bring great parts
for women to the screen and and so
appreciative that audiences are enjoying
them I called you a culture shifter the
last time I talked to you and it's it's
true the thing that I admire most about
you you're like I'm gonna get my gang of
girls together and we're just gonna kick
ass all the way through Hollywood we
have so much right and there's so many
women they're doing Charlie's is doing
Nicole is doing that Jennifer is doing
it's really exciting to see let's play a
little fashion fill in the blank before
I lose you okay three hours ago I was
wearing what a robe maybe like jeans and
a sweater okay
and then I change it to a robe and then
I changed into this what I love most
about this look is well I like that it's
white yeah but that's what I'm worried
about the most because I like to hug
people so it's like oh gosh and they
taught me makeup everywhere hug
everybody to make it fit it's fun it's
just fun to play with fashion